IBM Watson orchestrates integration with
this way Global new life cycle Services
added to Enterprise networking and the
IBM storage price and Supply guarantee
all on this episode of IBM Tech now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
to get the ball rolling this week IBM
Watson orchestrate has partnered with
this way Global to help Talent
acquisition professionals accelerate the
process of sourcing candidates
users work with their very own Watson
orchestrate digital employee which is
called a Digi to quickly create and post
open job requisitions
using the integration between Watson
orchestrate in this way Global your Digi
can pull a list of hundreds of
candidates whose skills match the
posting obtain your job posting from
your local repository and input the
information into this way Global
sourcing platform
Digi can then save the output of
candidates back to the same repository
and start the dialogue by emailing the
candidates on the list with an approved
template
simply put this integration will help
you expand the resource pool discover
strong existing candidates optimize
reach identify the best candidates and
use Fair recruitment practices
and by handing off tedious and
repetitive tasks to a digital employee
you can focus on higher level work like
setting Talent strategy interviewing and
building relationships
to learn more about how IBM Watson
orchestrate in this way Global can help
you find the perfect candidate and get
more time back in your day hit the link
below
next up as part of the IBM mission to
address the market demand for
Accelerated hybrid Cloud adoption we are
pleased to announce IBM has added life
cycle services to its Enterprise
networking business
as Enterprises integrate their on-site
it infrastructure with their hybrid
multi-cloud architecture Advanced
networking services and support become
increasingly important to meet their
users performance expectations
to that end IBM is building out
comprehensive life cycle Services
spanning deploy support optimize and
refresh service offers
these Services include rack and stack to
help you deploy and refresh Network
Hardware basic or lawn configuration
implementation to help you deploy
configure Network equipment and
performance assessments to provide you
with a comprehensive view of your
network identify present or potential
issues and suggest steps to mitigate or
optimize them
to learn more about IBM's plan for
technology lifecycle Services check out
the link I've got in the description of
this video
to wrap things up the folks over in IBM
storage are excited to announce that
we're bringing back our price and supply
chain guarantee and the why weight
deferred payment program
IBM storage is underwriting our
commitment that if we do not ship your
new eligible flash system purchase by
the end of 2022 we will provide you with
a one-year license to use IBM storage
insights pro at no charge
we also pledge to not increase prices
for any flash System model through the
end of 2022 to give you confidence to
move your purchasing decisions forward
additionally with the why wait financing
program when you purchase an eligible
IBM flash system product you can accept
delivery immediately and make no
payments for three months after that we
put together a payment structure of 33
equal monthly payments over a 36 month
period based on competitive interest
rates
to learn more about the specific terms
and eligible products for the price and
supply chain guarantee hit the link
below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now